uh let's hear from a couple of other
people
why don't we go to uh nathan from
california nathan you're on the air
hey david um
i work in the wedding industry and a uh
recently a local politician has gotten
some flack on the news for attending a a
private event and um
i just wanted to know your thoughts on
kind of like the hypocrisy of uh
politicians saying that you should wear
a mask indoors
while
they're attending these private events
yeah i mean listen there's obvious
hypocrisy there's no question about it
um also
sometimes public health guidelines
are supported
at a governmental level and individuals
assess their own risk and they do
different things i mean okay you know it
doesn't make it not hypocritical it just
is something that happens
um
i don't know about the event you know
sometimes people go to i've gone to a
couple of events where
everybody's got to be vaccinated and
gets a test on the way in and then like
i went to a dinner with 10 people like
that last month and that seemed quite
reasonable and and we don't know what
the testing requirement is i'm about to
go to a wedding where everybody's going
to be tested uh so i don't know i mean
of course there's some level of
hypocrisy and then at the same time i
think a lot of the stuff is in the
details
okay i mean uh do you think like at a
certain point like personal
responsibility will be kind of like the
like ultimately like the thing that
people will have to like take upon
themselves outside of like these mass
mandates yeah i mean i think it's going
to go more and more in that direction
and like dr isaac bogash last week told
us once we really have a high enough
level of vaccination and hopefully the
virus becomes less serious where the the
death risk goes down even more then it
becomes more about each individual
making the decision for themselves we're
not at that point right now for a number
of different reasons the virus is still
far more serious than the flu and not
not nearly enough people are vaccinated
so yes it's gonna go more and more
towards just personal decisions but
we're nowhere near that yet
awesome well thank you for taking my
call my pleasure very good question
appreciate it all right thanks everybody
who called in that's going to do it for
today we'll take calls again and i'll
speak to more people uh we'll take a
quick break and be right back